Water is amazing! It's necessary for life
to exist, makes you healthier, and it's incredibly
refreshing - especially after an intense workout.
But is water intoxication a real thing? Can
you drink too much water?
We're often told to drink around 8 glasses
of water a day to stay healthy - but the honest
truth is that this specific number is somewhat
arbitrary, and no scientific research exists
to support it. Regardless, we know water is
incredibly important; in fact, every organism
we know of requires water to survive. Not
only does it help the human body to bring
oxygen and nutrients to the cells, regulate
body temperatures and aid metabolism, but
it flushes waste out of the body. Sweat out
too much during a sporting event, and you'll
start to feel a bit woozy. Three days without
water, and you likely won't survive.
So how could such an essential substance hurt
us? It all comes down to the cellular level.
The water you drink has very few electrolytes
in it - things like sodium or potassium - especially
compared to your cells. The electrolytes in
your cells allow your muscles and nerves to
work properly, and help to control blood pressure
and blood volume. Without them, your body
cannot function. Now normally, the difference
in the electrolyte concentration inside and
outside the cell wouldn't pose a problem,
because your kidneys flush out any excess
water; however, the kidneys can only excrete
fluid at a certain rate. This means that consuming
a lot of water in a short period of time creates
a large concentration difference. As a result,
water is drawn into the cells in an attempt
to dilute the concentration and even out the
proportion of electrolytes, and this causes
the cells to swell.
The problem is, unlike other parts of your
body, the brain literally has no room inside
the skull for these newly plump cells. This
results in extreme headaches and confusion,
leading to seizures, comas, respiratory arrest
and even death.
So should you be worried? Not likely! Cases
of water intoxication are very rare, though
they do happen in extreme circumstances. Close
to 1/6th of marathon runners develop mild
cases in their careers, with all endurance
athletes at a higher risk. This is because
under the extremes of athletic stress, the
body attempts to conserve water. So not only
are you taking more water in, you're peeing
less out.
Science says, though you're not likely to
suffer from water intoxication, you should
drink to your thirst - it's the best indicator!
Don't forget: we have a new video out every day during the Olympics.
But if you can't wait, head to cbc.ca/olympics/ScienceSays for more.
Keep asking those burning questions with the hashtag ScienceSays, and subscribe for more awesome science videos!